welcome to the daily climate show coming
up
russia made nearly 80 billion pounds
from exporting fossil fuels in the first
100 days of the war in ukraine
as the cost of filling a car's tank
passes 100 pounds new analysis shows
that electric cars are now more than 60
cheaper to run
there's an alarming lack of credibility
in corporate net zero promises the
conclusion of new global research into
climate action and mary poppins meets
climate activism a creative protest
outside lloyds of london today
[Music]
and welcome to the daily climate show
where we track the changes happening to
our world hear from the people hit
hardest by those changes and we
challenge those coming up with the
solutions now we start today with the
star news that russia made a staggering
93 billion euros that's almost 80
billion pounds from exporting fossil
fuels in the first 100 days of its war
on ukraine well the analysis from the
center for research on energy and clean
air shows that despite attempts from
many countries to reduce dependence on
russian oil and gas the global energy
crunch has meant continued high profits
for moscow which in turn have financed
the invasion of ukraine
while about 61 of the fossil fuels were
exported to the eu in that time
including about 12.1 billion euros worth
to germany
but china became the world's largest
importer of russian energy in that time
importing some 12.6 billion euros worth
well laurie miliverto produced this
research and joins me now um lori it's
great to have you here um with us these
figures absolutely staggering there and
the question that many people will be
wondering is what impact have the
efforts from the west and around the
world had
on russia
there is a clear impact in the sense
that russian oil is selling for 30
percent less than oil from other
producers
and
the export volumes
from russia have fallen about 15 so
those two things show
um that
the dance and the the other efforts to
reduce
imports have had an impact
um but at the same time the energy
crunch has meant that that russia is
still making
record profits uh if you look a bit
longer term the fact that countries are
pledging
to completely stop um imports from
russia um that is is is going to have a
a strong long-term impact on on china's
economic outlook
and what do you make of the response
from the west so far the us eu and of
course also um the uk as well
what do you make of the efforts that
they've made to reduce the flow of cash
to russia
you can really see that it's
people who are used to thinking about
energy policy in terms of years or
decades trying to scramble a response to
uh to a crisis that is happening in the
matter in a matter of minutes and hours
and days um so we urgently need to move
faster than phasing things out by the
end of the year as as the eu is
said it will do with russian oil imports
or over the next years as it's talking
about with gas we need
to find ways to have a short short term
rapid impact one example of how that
could be done is that we've shown that
80 of the tankers carrying
russian oil to new markets such as
india and the middle east uh are
european and uh so that's something that
the european union could act on and stop
uh quite rapidly and we're seeing of
course that india and china are two of
the markets that are very much flowing
to russia at the moment he gets
obviously some much reduced oil and gas
what do you make of that relationship at
the moment how sustainable is it to plug
that gap that many countries from the
west are leaving by reducing the
dependency on oil and gas from russia
the gap is currently still quite small
um the eu is still produced it is still
purchasing half
of russia's oil exports
that about 20 reduction that we've seen
in
imports into the eu is something that
india in particular has been able to
to plug
to minimize and minimize the impact but
once the eu
starts to move towards a complete ban um
that's something that there is simply no
way
for russia to work around
the infrastructure the tanker capacity
um the refining capacity uh to do that
simply doesn't exist
laurie miller grateful for your time
thank you
thank you well let's get some more on
now on today's climate news and the
government's been criticized for a lack
of ambition and its plans to overhaul
the food system
the government's food strategy will be
revealed later today with ministers
promising that farm reform and food
security will be at its heart
however critics say that key parts of
the proposals from the government's own
food advisor have not been taken on
board such as a 30 reduction in the
consumption of meat and dairy seen as
key to reducing emissions from the
agriculture sector
the cost of driving an electric vehicle
is now more than 60 percent cheaper than
its petrol or diesel equivalent that's
according to new analysis
a surprise of filling an average family
car rises above 100 pounds carbon brief
website says that the equivalent cost
for an electric car is just 37 pounds
but replacing traditional vehicles with
evs is an important part of the global
strategy to meet net zero by 2050.
a group of mothers demonstrated outside
lloyds of london to show their
opposition
to the insurance of fossil fuels
the group behind the protest mothers
rise up say that they hope the action
will inspire lloyds to take more
ambitious climate action for the sake of
all children now lloyd's vision shows
about 40 of the global energy market has
committed to stopping the insurance of
fossil fuel projects by 2030.
now there's an alarming lack of
credibility in many corporate climate
promises that's according to new global
report now volunteers from net zero
tracker that's an organization based at
the university of oxford examined the
pledges that every country in the world
and of course hundreds of companies have
made
the research has found that net zero
targets now cover more than 90 percent
of global gdp
and 65 of greenhouse gas emissions
that's six times more than just a couple
of years ago
well that's the good news but when it
comes to corporations the news well
isn't so good
so let's bring in our climate reporter
who's of course victoria seabrook who
joins me now and victoria a bit of a
mixed picture isn't it some good some
not so good when it comes to this news
yes exactly so the good news is this
proliferation of net zero targets that
you've just touched on with those with
those numbers and that's really a
reflection of net zero
and and climate change and what we need
to do to tackle it becoming not just a
scientific consensus but political too
but the bad news is um what the report
is calling this major credibility gaps
in a lot of policies in particular those
that come from companies
so of the companies that it analyzed it
found that just one-third had a climate
target and of those two-thirds were
lacking a clear plan of how they were
even going to achieve it
and victoria just remind us what exactly
net zero means and why do companies need
such a detailed plan
yeah so net zero is all about reducing
the net amount of greenhouse gas
emissions that we're putting into the
atmosphere to zero and the way that
we're supposed to do that is first of
all cutting emissions as much as
possible and then own and only then
compensating for the rest with things
like carbon offsetting now 40 of these
companies plans are currently relying on
carbon offsetting but actually their use
is supposed to be very much limited
scientists say because of the great
amount of resources sometimes land and
money needed for them and also how
difficult it is to ensure that they're
permanent so they are supposed to be
reserved only for certain sectors and so
the over reliance on offsetting as well
as a few other lack of details in these
plans is really where these concerns are
coming up about a lack of credibility
and where corporations risk perhaps
being accused of green washing if they
don't come up with the detail
victoria thank you
well that is all from us for now thanks
for watching see you next time